have almost made it to the end of our first week of school
and honestly we have been way more productive than I thought we would be around
schooling really paid off for us this year
we finished up our study on the state of Delaware
and it has been a fan favorite
so I thought I'd share a little bit about how we handle US geography
for starters it is one of those subjects that I do a learning journal with
because I wanted to be able to use our curriculum
plus pull from our own experience
experiences in our own travel
we're using the our 50 States curriculum by Not Grass
my kids decided they wanted to start with the state that we have traveled to
so I put all of the names of those states in a jar
and we pick from one every time we're ready to study a new state
Madison pooled South Carolina as our next state
so to prepare I'm gonna make a copy of the state outline from the Not Grass workbook
then I'll print out some pictures from our trips to South Carolina
then I like to find a coloring page from the state on Google
I try to find one that includes like
state birds state flowers
state Free state animal
things like that and then on our next geography day
I'll read from the textbook while they colour the picture
they glue everything in their journal
we watch a homeschool pop video
and then we might do one of the activities in the book if we like
the next day we work on writing captions for the picture
and this is where I work on the writing skills
right now we're working on capitalization
how to abbreviate and how to write city commerces
as the year progresses
I'll start to add more writing prompts in for my second grade
and then we finish every state by coloring that state on our coloring
you have other questions about our geography study that I didn't answer
drop them in the comments